le secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
est l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
christian à coeur bonsoir et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation donc de
preuves par 3 sur public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse à un moment
d'extrême tension sociale et politique
tension également sur les économies
qu'il vous faut trouver sur le budget au
cours de cette émission et bien vous
répondrez à trois grandes questions
premièrement est ce que la cgt
finalement aura la peau de la loi
travail et partant peut-être du
gouvernement deuxième question tales and
oracle de bercy est-ce que vous allez
nous annoncer une baisse des impôts elle
est espéré dans le sépare les français
également par françois hollande mais
vous connaissez la difficulté de trouver
des marges de manoeuvre et c'est de cela
que dépend cette baisse des impôts pour
2010 est enfin troisième question alors
que les maires se réunissent en congrès
à la fin du mois est ce que vous allez
enfin entendre leur sos de droite comme
de gauche vous le savez les élus
comptent est votre vision de leur
situation financière
françois hollande et manuel valls à
l'unisson face au mouvement de grève et
au blocage qui se multiplient en france
un seul mot d'ordre la fermeté on écoute
le chef de l'état ça ne mérite pas une
forme de respect par rapport à ceux qui
ont des revendications légitimes mais ça
ne ne me convient pas non plus à
accepter ce qui est aujourd'hui un
blocage qui est fondée simplement par
une stratégie portée par une minorité
voilà un blocage aujourd'hui une
confrontation brutale la cgt
finira-t-elle par avoir la peau de la
loi travail
j'oserais hors de forme de votre
question parce que avant la pause est-ce
qu'on est aujourd'hui dans le
gouvernement
uniquement nubile et par l'idée d'avoir
la peau de quelqu'un ou de sauver sa
propre peau quand on est en
responsabilité au gouvernement de voir
cette faire en sorte que les conditions
économiques les conditions budgétaires
les conditions sociales permettent au
pays de progresser
il s'agit pas d'avoir la peau de l'un la
peau de l'autre
je crois qu'il faisait un mauvais coup à
l'ambition qu'elle venait de rappeler
une forme d'apaisement dans le débat le
débat a eu lieu l'été vif
il a même vu un peu à l'assemblée jean
temps j'entends dire que le 49-3 aurait
interrompu empêcher toute forme de débat
ils rament des travaux en commissions et
des débuts de travaux dans l'hémicycle
puisse être reprendre ils vont reprendre
au sénat puis à l'assemblée et des
discussions il ya eu des amodiations de
la loi des aménagements de la loi
certains disent qu'on a vidé la loi de
sa substance d'autres disent mais non ça
reste une loi extrêmement pénalisante
j'allais dire c'est peut-être aussi le
signe qu'on est dans une espèce de
légume est alors l'apaisement
l'apaisement vous appeler à l'apaisement
que peut faire le gouvernement
au début on pense d'abord que il faut
que les organisations syndicales
notamment la cgt mais pas que la cgt et
prenne nos responsabilités la
responsabilité c'est qu'au moment où au
moment où la croissance s'améliorent
ce que confirme aujourd'hui le fmi le
fmi il vient vient effectivement de
relever sa prévision de croissance
il était à a1 nous nous avons posé comme
il peut être un point cinq pour deux
externes
alors aujourd'hui le fait me dit oui on
aura une croissance en france de près de
1g telles importations elle dit qu'elle
prend ses responsabilités en bloquant
mais justement je pense qu'au moment où
la croissance reprend de façon plutôt
significative pour espérer mieux
c'est un mauvais coup qui peut être
porté à l'économie des journées grève
des journées de frilosité dans le monde
du travail dans les déplacements
c'est un réseau de l'élite au
conditionnel ça ne l'est déjà un mauvais
ou wii donc il est temps d'en sortir et
vous l'avez déjà chiffré ce mauvais coup
pour l'économie ou non en nombre pour
l'instant il est bien sûr trop tôt pour
en parler mais vous savez que tous les
élus tous les événements qui se passent
en france aussi un retentissement sur
l'attractivité de notre pays
ce soit en matière économique soit en
matière touristique et je pense qu'il
est temps maintenant d'en sortir mais
c'est pas du tout la voie qu'emprunte la
cgt vous avez vu la multiplication des
blocages l'appelle maintenant même à la
grève reconductible à la sncf à la fin
du mois oui une forme un peu de deux
dispersion en lançant un mouvement
reconductible à la sncf on annonce une
grève à la ratp
on a ces blocages dans les raffineries
dans les dépôts de carburant je crois
qu'il ya là une attitude que les
français d'ailleurs commence un petit
peu avant de recevoir vous attendez une
condamnation des français ceux qui se
lèvent le matin qui convenait et qui
parie sur l'avenir pour reprendre les
expressions des manuels macron évitons
les mots qui blessent les mots qui vexe
seront prises en otage je n'aime pas ce
vocabulaire
je n'aime pas sous quelle heure il
s'agit que chacun dans une situation qui
est difficile de cette solution
économique et social qui est tendu vous
l'avez dit il s'agit un moment donné de
directeur en remettons ce pays est en
marche c'est ce que nous faisons un
responsabilité en posant sa nombre de
principes dans la loi qui peuvent
changer l'état d'esprit qui peuvent
parfois interpellé ont souvent été mal
présentée d'ailleurs souvent caricaturée
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont en
train d'en prendre conscience que vous
aviez en face de vous faire plutôt que
moi philippe martinez le leader de la
cgt que lui diriez vous je lui dirai que
il ya eu des évolutions que il a
probablement lui un peu trop vite les
propositions qui sont contenues dans le
projet de loi et qu'il est temps
maintenant de de sortir par le haut de
cette difficulté parce que sinon il ya
un risque économique
effectivement c'est quand l'économie va
mal c'est finalement un risque social
qui se concrétise et des difficultés
souvent pour les gens les plus modestes
alors même si vous rejetez vous l'avez
dit d'emblée l'idée d'un passage en
force cette voie travail lui le patron
de la cgt dénonce un déni de démocratie
il rappelle que cette loi n'était pas au
programme de françois hollande en 2009
100 ha en 2000 dans mes soins en 2012 en
écoute là monsieur martinez le
gouvernement et le premier ministre en
particulier joue un jeu dangereux et
s'est divisé la cgt essayer d'opposer la
cgt aux citoyens
c'est y était opposée la cgt aux
salariés je préviens tout de suite le
gouvernement attention à ne pas
s'opposer au droit de grève c'est une
décision de l'organisation
internationale du travail
nous sommes déterminés à aller jusqu'au
bout en tout cas nous nous appelons à
une généralisation des grèves partout
dans tous les secteurs variés alors
c'est pas l'appel à la responsabilité
l'un que vous espérez donc bien sûr mais
pour répondre à votre question sur
l'exercice de la démocratie et du droit
de grève
nous avons entendu la démocratie à la
son rythme à la son calendrier
elle pose des échéances a confié un
moment donné l'exercice du pouvoir pour
des durées limitées
avec forcément une délégation d'exercice
du pouvoir au nom du peuple français à
ses gouvernants ça n'autorise pas tout
et n'importe quoi mais je crois que ces
présidents qui disait ça l'autre jour
sur une grande radio à matin est ce que
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
on pouvait anticiper ce qui se passe sur
le terrorisme par exemple ou sur des
questions internationales lourde qui se
sont posés à lui quelques mois quelques
années après son arrivée là le travail
c'est pas une réaction à l'actualité et
dramatique là c'est un programme et tu
crois qu'elle est issue d'une prise de
conscience très forte du manque de
compétitivité de notre pays de nos
entreprises
on l'a vu faire intervenue après 2000
dont la vue sur les questions des marges
des entreprises nous avons restauré les
machines entreprise je pense que on en
reparlera peut-être dans cette émission
oui c'était important c'est est
essentiel aujourd'hui les grandes
entreprise ces observateurs de la vie
économique internationale reproche à la
france non plus le manque de marge aux
entreprises encore plus tellement la
question de la fiscalité qui reste un
problème mais qui s'est estompée au en
tout cas qui a diminué d'intensité suite
aux mesures que nous avons prises et le
principal argument qui est mise en avant
par les investisseurs internationaux
c'est la question du marché du travail
et les contraintes qu'il impose et qui
ne sont pas les mêmes dans la nuit voire
de l'europe du fmi puisque on l'évoquait
il ya un instant qui par ailleurs
aujourd'hui dans sa note ainsi que la
france allait encore plus loin que la
loi y compris donc il faudra aller plus
loin j'ai rencontré la délégation du fmi
qui lorsqu'il vient
en france beaucoup d'acteurs entre
autres je les ai vus ont effectivement
ont dit qu'ils allaient relever la
prévision de croissance mais on a évoqué
aussi ces questions de marché du travail
qui sont une préoccupation
on dit parfois que c'est bruxelles qui a
préoccupé qui donne des injonctions et
que c'est pas bruxelles seulement c'est
aussi le fmi mais c est vous avez raison
il a raison aussi un constat connu dans
un monde concurrentiel dans une
concurrence internationale on peut être
lourd on peut être contre
c'est une réalité d'aujourd'hui de la
réalité c'est que la loi travail n'est
qu'une étape
écoutez il ya eu enfin on a présenté la
loi macron la loi un croissance activité
comme étant une première étape on a
présenté la loi travail quitte
aujourd'hui devant le parlement comme
une deuxième étape
prenons les choses comme elles viennent
aujourd'hui c'est une étape en tout cas
que événements et des spas déjà le
ministre dit une amie franchi entre
collègues de mercier même à condé dans
les échos ce matin qu'il faudra aller
plus loin par exemple aussi négocié au
niveau des entreprises des salaires
écoutez bien président et un premier
ministre bis route l'économie est un
acteur parmi d'autres au sein du
gouvernement ou bien on en reparlera
parce que j'entends vos réserves est ce
qu'il faut aller jusqu à réquisitionner
le personnel dans certaines raffineries
pour que la france ne soit pas à sec
on apprécie la situation propre à
l'exclure risque au jour le jour
moi je n'exclus rien j'étais aujourd'hui
en province en tout rejoindre discuter
avec le le préfet aujourd'hui on a aussi
un phénomène pardon rentrer dans ses
dents c'est ce qui peut apparaître comme
des détails c'est que les gens devant
seul risque de pénurie stocks de
carburant qu'on a on a finalement un
phénomène qui rajoute de la pénurie à ce
qui peut ce qui peut manquer dans les
dépôts de carburants nancy des dépôts
stratégie qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre en
cas de besoin tout ça est géré par les
ministres concernés
alors vous avez évoqué l'attractivité de
la france est en recul certaines selon
certaines études et il ya quelques
heures
le pdg de total monsieur puyané a dit
que sa société et bien menacé de réviser
ses investissements en france en raison
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans ses
raffineries comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à cette annonce et cette
menace
total est une société multinationale qui
a l'habitude de dispatcher dispatcher
pendant ses investissements au travers
et mende en comptant beaucoup environ
source pétrolière en fonction des
besoins en fonction des capacités
techniques de raffinage notamment c'est
pas nouveau que total adapte la fête
elle a souvent fait des adaptations de
ses stratégies que le mythe pour des
raisons fiscales
elle m'a été reproché d'ailleurs juste
titre je crois qu'elle a un peu changé
de position donc essayons là encore de
retrouver un peu le sens du dialogue de
la sérénité totale est une grande
multinationale d'origine française donc
totale est une grande entreprise sous
l'état aussi parfois un rôle à jouer
mais quand son pdg dit qu'ils les
fassent aujourd'hui à une forme de
rupture entre son entreprise et ses
salariés qui bloquent les raffineries
vous l'entendez vous le comprenez bien
sûr sur la majorité en tous cas la
totalité des salariés qui ont
suffisamment prévu à l'horizon du
diamant nombreux pour gagner vite avec
encore qu'on connaît oui enfin des
difficultés qu'on arrive à lever je
crois qu'ils sont honteux de raffineries
qui ont été évacués par les fonds sont
sans grand incident pour l'instant
facebook que tout ça aussi dur parce que
y'a aussi des violences il ya des
blocages qui pénalise l'économie ou où
la vie des gens mais il ya aussi des
formes de violence qui sont les siennes
en forme de rupture sont élargies entre
la cgt aujourd'hui du pacte entre la cgt
et le pays
pas sûr que le sujet était signé un
pacte avec le pays c'est par une
signature n'est pas trace et la cgt
n'est quand même pas le seul la seule
organisation syndicale de ce pays à son
nombre d'organisations syndicales qui se
sont inscrits dans des démarches
différentes de se lancer j'étais alors
en entendez votre appel à l'apaisement
mais certains estiment que la
radicalisation actuelle découle de la
déception du pouvoir de gauche depuis
l'élection de françois hollande je vous
propose d'écouter jean luc mélenchon qui
a encore haussé le ton tout à l'heure ça
suffit du gouvernement maintenant je dis
aval sur l'ongle c'est bon quoi
arrêté parce que c'est pas la peine
d'aller faire des gesticulations sur
jaurès et le reste est de dire au
secours la droite de revient est de
faire pire que tout ce qu'on a jamais vu
dans ce pays en matière de brutalité
sociale de loi injuste et de
persécutions contre les travailleurs
jamais personne
au cours des 15 dernières années n'a
parlé à la cgt à force ouvrière comme
vous êtes en train de le faire mais qui
vous aide pour vous permettre ça qui
vous a élu quel est votre famille
politique que d'autre que vous le fasse
on pourrait le comprendre
après tout ce serait dans l'ordre de la
polémique démocratique mais vous vous
n'avez pas le droit de parler comme ça
valls et hollande
si vous êtes pour qui vous prenez vous
qui vous êtes
lance jean luc mélenchon que lui
répondez-vous aux jeunes enfants est
habitué des formules des formules vous
dites qu'ils haussent le ton ce qui
avait valu mal à hausser le ton avec ce
qu il est un peu à fond moi je crois
qu'il faut dire clairement les choses
aux français nous avons un pays qui a
pris du retard en matière de
compétitivité
peut-être ne l'at-on pas suffisamment
mesuré dans un seau nombre de deux
circonstances où c'est les élections
sont souvent propres aussi à faire de la
surenchère à faire parfois dé prendre
parfois des engagements pas toujours
suffisamment mesuré crois que c'est un
barman non mais tu ailles avant journal
du soir qui a instamment ont fait part
d'un certain nombre d'analystes
d'anciens ministres du gouvernement
sacrifie le chef je crois qu'il y avait
surtout il y avait surtout ce sentiment
de dire que tu es on a découvert une
situation qui était finalement plus
grave que celle qu'on a qu'on avait
parlé des mesures de gauche s'étaient
enfin moi je n'ai pas trouvé que m
enfin on n'a peut-être pas la même la
rue rachel est lu attentivement parce
que oui je trouve que je les connais
pour certains d'entre eux très
personnellement donc ça vous apparaissez
voir ce qui m'a ce qui m'a surpris sur
l'opportunité de ce type de déclarations
à un moment où les tensions sont fortes
mais en tout cas sur le fond moi je
comprends ces déclarations je vois plus
calme m certains moments mais après
c'est le prime vient de tenir ses bas
écouter on a tous découvert des choses
qui n'étaient pas forcément connu
l'ampleur des déficits les impasse
budgétaire pour ramener un domaine que
je connais
peu les questions fiscales les
difficultés de certaines administrations
les impasse budgétaire qui avait été
fait
ça faisait quand même énormément alors
pression souvenez vous la pression
l'euro dont l'avenir était incertain la
pression de bruxelles
ça fait quand même temps en temps on a
perdu ce type de situation avait été
victime de ce que vous avez découvert à
propos de mélenchon bien dit encore que
le gouvernement là et qui êtes-vous
lance-t-il veut créer le désordre pour
se présenter ensuite en sauveur qu'est
ce que vous pensez de nom il va on n'est
pas dans ce type de stratégie quand on
est responsable on est au gouvernement
on ne joue pas avec le pays
on ne joue pas des stratégies qui
seraient des stratégies électorales or
si nous n'avions qu'une stratégie
électorale callen terrier qu'elle
intégrait pardon aurions nous à prendre
des mesures dont on mesure parfois la
difficulté pour nos compatriotes alors
comprendre les critiques de droite
maintenant élevé surtout un pouvoir qui
a entravé qui est disqualifié comme le
dit alain juppé en écoute l'ancien
premier ministre
gouvernement celle où dans un mauvais
départ en engageant une réforme
pas un nom célèbre pièce que je fais des
rares fois ces électeurs c'est
parlementaire c'est ce qu'explique le
trouble profond aujourd'hui à la fois
élu par le comprendre
monsieur qui travaillait quelques joints
de s'alimenter naissance
je vais rapide et efficace reprise
suffit pas d'annoncer offert à la gp10
que les électeurs n'ont pas voté à
gauche pour avoir cette politique
il est quand même côté surf je crois
qu'il a connu lorsqu'il était premier
ministre de ce pays
la zone nombre de situations qu'on peut
au moins dire comparables je suis pas
sûr que lui aussi s'était engagé à
apporter des textes qui l'a finalement
d'ailleurs retiré lorsqu'il a été
premier ministre
donc un peu là aussi de responsabilités
d'humidité n'ouvre une situation qu'il
faut affronter courageusement le
gouvernement le fait courageusement
premier ministre a clairement indiqué
les choses c'est qu'elle était sa
volonté d'aboutir et la différence donc
entre manuel valls et alain juppé sait
que le premier ministre actuel tiendra
bon on nous le confirmer ce soir au
château différence
ah oui mais celle ci a je pense que le
premier ministre est parfaitement
déterminé
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas dû rentrer un
peu plus tôt et d'israël
il était en israël alors que la crise
couvait s'amplifier dans notre pays où
tu le dit lui-même les moyens modernes
de communication et de gestion
permettent aujourd'hui de faire des
choses parfois à distance je crois qu'il
avait pris un engagement
il y avait d'ailleurs une situation avec
israël kim a été d'être clarifiés je
crois suite un certain nombre de votes
et de décision il était utile aussi
parce que ça aussi son importance la
politique internationale alors deuxième
partie maintenant des preuves par 3 et
christian vainqueur à verre avec lucile
malandain de l' agence france-presse
c'est cette question est ce que vous
êtes favorable à une baisse des impôts
et l'espère et je le disais par les
français mais également par françois
hollande la question semble farfelu au
moment où vous relancer à bercy le
processus d'économies à tout va les
critiques de l'opposition par la voix
d'albéric de montgolfier rapporteur
général
les républicains de la commission des
finances du sénat est-ce que tu assez
paradoxal c'est que le parlement comme
vous savez votre loi de finances en
décembre et l'autre finances
rectificatif à décembre et quelques
semaines après
le vote du parlement à bien le présent
la république annonce des mesures pour
plus d'un milliard ce plan de l'emploi
plus des mesures sur les agriculteurs
plus des mesures nouvelles tous les
jours et certains de plus de 4 milliards
d'euros et ça pose la question de la
sincérité d'un budget qui est très
largement modifié par les annonces de
l'exécutif
et ces annonces ne sont évidemment pas
financé et en tous les cas soit de la
prévisibilité parfois parce que la
question de lure de l'emploi c'est
certaine urgence mais c'est pas quelque
chose qui on découvre du jour au
lendemain je vous rappelle qu'on est
passé à plus de 2000 milliards d'euros
de dette
et puis on est le seul pays on est venu
dans l'union européenne
le seul pays peut être que la croatie
qui laisse filer son déficit alors que
les autres pays ont fait des efforts
drastiques et en tous les cas on le
risque évidemment c'est qu'on s'éloigne
pour financer notamment assad annonce à
la prochaine présidentielle
voilà pourquoi qu'il a un instant par
quentin calme et bonsoir laisser ma
langue haoussa alors vos questions le
secrétaire d'état au budget alors mac et
ma première question c'est allez vous
annoncer une baisse d'impôts comme le
souhaite le président de la république
on s'oriente qui en a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois pour 2017
je suis en paix tant je vais faire deux
préalables le premier c'est que vous
avez tout à l'heure présenté comme un
oracle de bercy oui je n'aurais pas
cette prétention j'y reviendrai dans un
instant la deuxième c'est ce que dit le
rapporteur général du budget au sénat si
choquant sur la sincérité non ce qui
choque ans et qui dit on est le seul
pays qui laisse filer les déficits
les déficits publics a baissé sans
interruption depuis 2012 il était à 5,1
pour cent
il est aujourd'hui à 3,6 pour une 5 %
fin 2015 c'est ce n'est pas rendre
service au pays que de dire avec les
efforts que l'on a demandé à tout le
monde on y reviendra sur les
collectivités territoriales avec les
efforts que l'on demandé à tout le monde
de ne pas reconnaître que le beh que le
déficit public a baissé
qu'on dise qu'il n'a pas suffisamment
baissé qu'on a peut-être pas pris les
bons outils pour le faire baisser
c'est son droit j'allais dire ce débat
démocratique mais dire des contrevérités
pareil pour moi c'est choquant 11% alors
la question donc bah on la formule à
nouveau parce qu'elles sont
oh est-ce qu'il va y avoir une nouvelle
baisse d'impôts en 2017 après celle de
2015 2016 alors que vous pouvez nous
l'annoncer c'est faisable est-ce que
vous en aurez plus l'oracle de mercer
effet vous le président de la république
a été très clair
présent dans le public a dit nous
verrons en fonction des marges qui
seront devant nous quels seront les
possibilités pour avoir des baisses
d'impôts l'année prochaine nous le
souhaitons ces baisses d'impôt nous
avons commencé vous avez eu la
gentillesse l'objectivité de rappeler
qu'effectivement ça a été le cas en 2015
les prélèvements obligatoires dire
l'ensemble de ce que le l'état en tous
cas les collectivités publiques
demandent comme contribution ont baissé
en 13 langues blanc les champions
d'europe 1 oui m'enfin sont baissées
aurait aussi le champion d'europe sur un
certain nombre de prestations que l'on
fournit à nos concitoyens au parler de
la santé on peut parler de la retraite
etc
mais c'est la peau l'impôt sur le revenu
puisque vous en parlez c'est le moment
d'une déclaration d'impôts les français
effectivement son sont concernés sur
l'impôt qu'il est et touche plus laisser
passer pas d'ailleurs le plus important
pour le pays nous sommes maintenant fin
du mois de mai d'une année budgétaire
aujourd'hui comment voulez-vous alors
même que les français sont seulement en
train de remplir leur déclaration
d'impôts que je sache que nous sachions
à bercy avec nos équipes
combien les recettes de l'état vont être
pour cette année en cours une année qui
est à peine commencée les recettes de
tva ont prié les résultats sur un
précédent d'annoncer des baisses
d'impôts donc vous mais parce que nous
avions deux vous aurez this way
mais non je suis prudent on peut pas
entendre des bonnes prévisions de
croissance confirmée par là le fmi
l'année dernière à la même époque
conduisez votre prophète prévisions de
croissance ne sera pas atteinte il va
vous manquer 10 milliards de recettes
à la fin de l'année il a manqué 0
milliards de recettes elles ont été
conformes à nos prévisions sont plus
optimistes que le président de la
république lui a clairement indiqué
clairement indiqué nous en sommes
s'expliquer avec lui michel s'appelle
mois
entre autres avec le premier ministre a
clairement indiqué que nous ferons le
point à fin du mois de juin au début du
mois de juillet lorsque nous aurons
affiner nos prévisions de recettes pour
cette année et qu'en fonction
effectivement des tendances qui seront
confirmées ou infirmées en fonction de
l'évolution de leurs sept enfants sont
les taux d'intérêt en fonction de la
croissance qui sera constaté aujourd'hui
on connaît les résultats du premier
trimestre et encore 14 juillet je sais
pas si ça sera le 14 juillet le 13 ou le
ou au début du mois de septembre la loi
de finances sera présenté au conseil des
ministres
comme tous les ans à la fin du mois de
septembre mais ça aura quand même le
dernier mercato septembre en général
écoutez si les marges apparaissent je
confirme et peuvent se quantifier on
verra sous quelle forme
vous allez me dire est ce que ça veut
dire que les différentes les nouvelles
dépenses que vous avez annoncé depuis
janvier qui sont intervenus comme comme
disait ce sénateur très très très
rapidement après le vote de la loi de
finances rectificative de fin d'année
est ce que ça veut dire qu'elles ont été
tellement importante que finalement la
fameuse redistribution par le françois
hollande depuis un an ou deux et déjà
fait en fin de cette manière et que
finalement ce n'est plus par l'impôt que
vous allez la poursuivre pour suivre
éventuellement mais ce que ce que vous
oubliez les uns les autres c'est que les
baisses d'impôts par exemple pour les
entreprises elles ont déjà eu lieu là le
1er avril les cotisations sociales tout
le monde l'a oublié mes cotisations
sociales des employeurs ont baissé de
pour pour près de 4 milliards d'euros en
mai le chef de l'état libyen après les
entreprises les ménages mais les mines
il ya eu des mesures vers des ménages on
nous a clairement rappelé mais
aujourd'hui nous avons annoncé 4
milliards effectivement de dépenses
supplémentaires
fallait-il ne pas les peler les mettre
en oeuvre ces mesures
fallait-il ne pas répondre à la crise
agricole avec près de 900 millions
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires sur
des réductions de cotisations
agriculteurs fallait il ne pas mettre en
oeuvre la privant une embauche qui
marche bien
le plan de formation qui va nous coûter
avec la prime à l'embauché autour de 2
milliards d'euros
qui était aligné une parure comme les
mesures électoralistes but et ils les
augmenter laissons ce qui compte est que
ces mesures là porter la critique les le
point d'indicé a été bloqué pendant cinq
ans cinq ans c'est beaucoup d'efforts
qui a été demandé un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires même si nous avons pas
mais regardez la campagne la catégorie
des mesures demandées aux ministères
russes ont supprimé des fonctionnaires
une baisse des effectifs de 2 % c'est
aussi la conséquence de l'augmentation
du poids dames il ne s'est pas nouveau
ça veut dire nous nous avons une
stabilité globale nous avions une
stabilité globale de nos effectifs
durant les trois premières années de la
législature avec une augmentation des
enseignants une hausse du nombre
d'enseignants avec une augmentation du
nombre de policiers avec une
augmentation du nombre de personnels de
la justice
nous avons donc baisser nos
fonctionnaires dans un salon de services
à bercy dans service des finances
publiques nous supprimions environ 2000
postes tous les ans c'est la masse
salariale des fonctionnaires
il n'y a pas une baisse de la masse à
elle a augmenté de 0 9% jours ci au
passage que ce chiffre le plus faible
depuis des années à l'augmenter
traditionnellement de 1 5%
elle n'a augmenté si je veux dire que de
0 9%
donc il ya eu une maîtrise en tout cas
même c'est pas une baisse de la masse
salariale
parce qu'il ya quand même la promotion
chez les fonctionnaires qui conduisent
naturellement même su points à 10 est
gelée à une augmentation de revenus
donc ces 4 milliards c'est ce que nous
n'avions fait l'année dernière année
dernière en cours d'année on a vu des
mesures sur la sécurité on avait eu
démesurément milliards l'opposition
notamment monsieur carette de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
conteste ce chiffre et parle de plus
notre plutôt de 6 milliards sinon ça il
a reconnu que ses troupes et gt gt à la
commission des finances il ajoute des
dépenses de 2016 à des dépenses de 2017
je reviens à la baisse d'impôts hérités
quercy en fait vous êtes coincé par le
chef de l'état il a annoncé qu'il y
aurait est ce que j'ai l'air d'être quoi
écouter
jamais lancé le chef de l'état à partir
il a annoncé en tout cas n'est pas la
retraite avait la présidence je suis moi
j'ai une des deux voies selon l'émission
est sous pression
c'est de réduire les déficits qu'il ya
deux moyens de réduire les déficits
c'est d'augmenter les recettes par des
augmentations d'impôts il n'en est pas
question
à rome sur une stratégie de réduction
des impôts nous l'avons déjà fait et
nous continuerons à le faire mais si
nous n'arrivons pas à contenir les
dépenses de façon suffisante
on ne pourra pas réduire les impôts et
réduire le déficit en même temps mais
j'observe c'est très important qu'en
2015 c'est ce que nous avons fait en
2015 nous avons réduit le déficit public
et nous avons réduit les prélèvements
obligatoires donc les impôts
nous l'avons fait en 2015 et nous avions
des dépenses supplémentaires notamment
sur les questions des verts l'euro est
toujours très bas et le taux d'intérêt
des jours précédents s'est pas
complètement un hasard non plus dresser
vous pouvez le faire quand même fait
quand même plaisir que vous avez déjà
estimé une masse en milliards ce savoir
et c'est trop tôt et fort
au total j'ai commencé bien j'ai
commencé par faut parler de l'oracle je
dis je il faut toujours garder de
l'humilité par rapport aux prévisions
regardez l'insee a révisé à la hausse la
croissance 2014
yahiaoui jour quinze jours et elle n'a
pas révisé de d'un petit peu elle a
multiplié par trois avec le recul vous
rendez compte
et aujourd'hui vous me demandez moi
d'avoir croix de bois croix de fer une
prévision de croissance nickel en 2010
est attendu que vous parlez de 7,7
prévient enfin de cette croissance
révisée par l'insee
puis ce qu'est ce que ça dit delà de la
valeur qu'on te donner aux statistiques
et deux de ces chiffres qu'on donne
chaque année y compris d'ailleurs ceux
du déficit
voilà les statistiques j'ai tendance à
penser que lorsqu elle repose sur des
constats c'est à dire sur le passé sont
plutôt fiables
même si m6 a eu quelques révisions
effectivement ils comparaissent un pur
par an rappelle que lindsay un comptable
national indépendant reconnu par
eurostat par la commission comme étant
un des
non c'est pas le gouvernement c'est
vraiment l'insee je peux vous dire
d'ailleurs qu'il ya une séparation
extrêmement fortes au moment où l'insee
joue son rôle de comptable national
fermons cette parenthèse par contre pour
l'avenir chacun comprendra que les
prévisions pour l'avenir dépendent bien
entendu de ce qui se passe chez nous des
pentes parfois vous l'avez rappelé de ce
qui se passe dans le contexte ton
intérêt prix du pétrole croissance
mondiale commerce mondial dépend aussi
de la situation internationale un
conflit par exemple peut avoir des
conséquences économiques importantes y
compris chez nous et donc il faut
toujours avoir une crainte n est ni
bonne en terme à plus court terme
sept prix nobel vous l'avez vu dénoncent
la suppression de 200 millions d'euros
de crédits un coup de massue distille un
suicide scientifiques et industriels
alors que vous avez défendu
monsieur le ministre l'attractivité de
la france il ya un instant alors vous m
tu es donc l'attractivité et le
dynamisme de la france en danger
notamment c'est ce que dit jean jouzel
du giec recherche est extrêmement
compétitive faut bien comprendre ça
disons il ya une compétition au niveau
international est effectivement à chaque
fois qu'on prend du retard et bien je
crois qu'on ne le rattrape paris cette
coupe budgétaire allemand risque de
romans de briser cette dynamique qui est
en place actuellement qui est
relativement disons normal pour un pays
comme la france dont on aimerait qu'elle
soit +10 en plus forte en tout cas pas
plus faibles comme celle qu'on nous
annonce aujourd'hui oui alors je vais
pas rentrer dans les détails eu des
chiffres c'est pas deux sens et 114
millions d'euros mais qu'on budgétaire
c'est pas le bon terme
qu'est ce que l'on a fait en bonne
gestion des deniers publics
nous avons regardé quels étaient les
trésoreries des grands opérateurs de
recherche notamment le cnrs le ceva et
deux autres opérateurs
ces réserves budgétaires c'est
trésorerie budgétaire qui ne sont pas
actives et qui sont activés au moment
des dépenses étaient pour certaines
dentelle trop importante
et enlever ses gaffes et de coupes
budgétaires
d'accord avec vous en principe ils
investissaient que d'écouter les couples
au moment où les besoins de décaissement
se feront il y aura les moyens
nécessaires parce que les programmes
d'investissements dans la recherche sont
pas des programmes qui se déclenchent du
jour au lendemain
joe des programmes qui sont programmés
et nous avons suivi très attentivement
la trésorerie de ces organismes cnrs il
ya plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros de trésorerie
est-ce qu'il serait aujourd'hui
compréhensible qu au moment où on
demande des efforts à l'ensemble des
acteurs publics
il y ait des réserves il y en a au cnrs
il y en a peu au ca je le concède il y à
il ya un travail à poursuivre et
approfondir je les dis d'ailleurs devant
la commission des finances la semaine
dernière l'assemblée nationale par
contre je dis les trésoreries qui ne
sont pas mobilisés que ce soit pour les
organismes de recherche
que ce soit la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie c'était khan un des nerfs
que ce soit dans les collectivités
locales on encore à tout à l'heure
mais il ya ce soit dans les organismes
hlm il y à un certain nombre de
trésorerie dormance que s'assigne ça
aujourd'hui nous en avons besoin pour
pouvoir tout cas l'idée des chercheurs
est ce que ça signifie que à force de
faire des économies les communions
commencer en 2012 l on était quand même
très importante
mon approche les autour des 60 milliards
si je me trompe pas quand même cinq ans
tué sur le quinquennat
est ce que ça veut dire qu'au bout d'un
moment on touche le dur au bout d'un
moment on touche des choses qui sont
aussi importantes que les budgets de la
recherche y compris six essais pour des
questions comptables une histoire de
trésorerie alors que justement le
président avait dit lui-même que c'était
des budgets qui serait complètement
sanctuariser qui est extrêmement plus
que je répète le budget n'est pas mis en
cause sont les trésoreries mais moi je
souhaite bien du plaisir à ceux qui
aujourd'hui pattes les estrades main en
annonçant 100 milliards d'euros on en
parlera des couinements 100 milliards de
rauzan pour leurs adhérents
c'est à dire le double que de ce que
nous avons fait et à la suite de ce que
nous avons fait aujourd'hui
on a eu quelques difficultés avec la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale pour des économies d'un
véhicule un milliard d'euros et
aujourd'hui les candidats
j'observe
la grand parti qu'il est candidat à la
primaire pour en parler en parler
annonce 100 milliards d'euros
d'économies quand j'ai dit ça aux
parlementaires de droite et au président
carrese notamment certains ont commencé
à regarder leurs godasses comme j'ai
l'habitude de dire non oui parce que les
économies tout le monde les réclames les
français les réclames la presse les
réclames le efféminé réclame le
gouvernement les les pouces et
parlementaires les ventes mais quand on
les fait c'est toujours chez les autres
qu'il faut le faire et bien aujourd'hui
on entraîne l'ensemble du pays dans un
mouvement d'économie une question nous
conduisons une question sur les
pressions sur google qui est soupçonné
de fraude fit fraude fiscale également
en france il ya une perquisition du
siège parisien ce matin du du géant
américain
on sait que ça fait suite à une plainte
de l'administration fiscale
est ce que le bras de fer là se durcit
avec avec google dans le biais de la
justice
un jours merci beaucoup de me poser
cette question le bras de fer il a
toujours été dur contrairement à ce qui
est dit parfois où ce que certains
peuvent penser légitimement nous sommes
astreints que je suis astreint au secret
fiscal
donc je ne peux pas aujourd'hui vous
dire combien les cas elle dans quel
délai devrait quand même on sait que
google est menacée d'un redressement
d'un milliard trois cents millions c'est
vous qui le dites c'est moi qui le dis
vous qui le dites
ce principe a démenti tout départ dont
on sait que je ne peux pas vous démentir
je vous donne un exemple d'offre
cinq entreprises multinationales l'année
dernière en 2015 ont fait l'objet de
redressements fiscaux et de pénalités
pour 3,3 milliards d'euros à cinq et à 5
seulement nous avons redressé 3,3
milliards d'euros de d'impôts et de
pénalités
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ce
gouvernement
et c'est pour le moins une nouveauté est
un gouvernement qui travaille sur les
questions de fiscalité qui poursuit un
surnombre d'entreprise nous ne faisons
pas de publicité aujourd'hui c'est le
parquet nationaux et financier mais vous
avez vous avez rappelé que c'était sur
la plaindre oui
sur la base des plaintes d'ailleurs de
la direction chez nous la justice les
magistrats financiers sont à vie et dans
cette partie femme et vous recevez en
tant que ministre est ce que vous seriez
prêt à une transaction à mur gueule non
il n'y a pas de transactions dans ce
pays nous avons été sollicité plusieurs
fois et que ça s'est passé en bretagne
mais vit ça s'est passé entre eux et
vous avez vu qu'elle a été le montant
des retraites
la somme espérée initialement beaucoup
moins que la somme et ses dentelles à
gérer l'eau qui danse art en tout cas
c'est le fisc aujourd'hui qui a notifié
le redressement
si google souhaite google et d'autres
souhaitent aller au bout des procédures
ils iront au bout des procédures mais
nous ne ferons pas de transactions sur
ce type de situation c'est clair et net
on va parler de politique maintenant
notamment avec michael zamit sont comme
une question est ce que le prélèvement à
la source vraiment entrera en
application dans les délais indiqués
voulue par le chef de l'état parce que
j'ai l'impression que la machine se
grippe un peu alors pas du tout ma page
le texte a été finalisée je peux vous le
dire hier il a été transmis où il doit
être transmis aujourd'hui au conseil
d'état et nous serons donc en mesure de
présenter ce texte au parlement dans la
loi de finances de 2010 est comme nous
l'avons indiqué et donc nous sommes
prêts à vous il ya beaucoup de
difficultés quand même
d'abord c'est une réforme que brême est
magnifique avec de faire c'est une
réforme qui souhaitaient attendu c'est
une réforme vous qui dit souvent qu'on
est les champions du monde et d'europe
c'est là nous sommes le seul pays
d'europe à ne pas pratiquer le problème
en agence
donc nous sommes prêts nous avons et
le calendrier tout à fait connu s'est
tenue mediaset et 1er janvier 2018 si
dieu nous prête vie
le prélèvement la raison car on sera en
vigueur merci laissez-le mais qu'elle
abaisse donc depuis mercenaires arrive
maintenant monsieur et caire pour vous
poser cette question est ce que vous
allez entendre enfin le sos des
collectivités locales les maires de
droite et de gauche vous réclame vous le
savez là encore des marges de manoeuvre
des comptes est votre vision sur leur
compte
c'était par exemple le cas il ya quinze
jours ici même à votre place notre
terroir 3 vous de gérard collomb le
sénateur maire socialiste de lyon on
écoute ce que me dit monsieur eckert et
alors là je m'inscris en faux contre lui
et je veux dire qu'on peut mener un
débat quand il le veut aujourd'hui vous
allez avoir une baisse de
l'investissement des collectivités
locales qui va être relativement forte
et vous allez le voir dans les deux
années qui viennent
nous sommes cinquante neuf maires dans
ma communauté urbaine il peut les
prendre les uns après les autres
il y en aura aucun qui va lui dire que
c'est pas hyper compliqué de boucler un
budget michèle manceaux monsieur caron
soit veut savoir vous êtes trop débat
avec gérard collomb ah oui quand vous
voulez ma vie très organisé
je suis toujours dire ce soir parce
qu'elle vous interpelle oui moi je peux
lui répondre tu me il le sait d'ailleurs
qu'est qu'est ce que j'ai dit qu'est ce
que je maintiens sur la situation
financière des collectivités
territoriales et des dotations de l'état
représentent un quart des recettes des
collectivités territoriales
ce car nous l'avons baissé de 8% oui 2.2
vous avez baiser les dotations 8 imiter
oui pour ça représente pour le quart de
leurs recettes
une baisse significative 3,66 milliards
environ mais ça va le reste le reste des
recettes des collectivités territoriales
le recettes fiscales
que ce soit les impôts locaux que ce
soit la cvae pardon de ses mots sa
technique
oui ben arfa ce sont des impôts que paye
toutes les entreprises cvae la
contribution foncière des entreprises
tous les saint preuil mutation des
droits d'inscription dans ça on va pas
morte et ont augmenté sans variation des
tours de façon considérable pourquoi
tout simplement parce que les bases sont
révisés tous les ans pour certaines
d'entre elles et pour d'autres notamment
les dm théo les droits de mutation comme
vous l'évoquez mais nos questions
augmentez val de marque géant immobilier
s'est décoincé et donc quand on regarde
l'ensemble de leurs recettes elles n'ont
pas baissé
elles ont augmenté de 1 70% pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
pris ce que vous avez dit c'est à dire
que les mesures que vous avez mis en
place et cette baisse des dotations pour
est-ce qu'il vous dise aujourd'hui c'est
une provocation on ne vous croit pas que
parce que ils ont été habitués à une
situation beaucoup plus confortable est
ce que vous croyez que c'est facile pour
l'état de réunir les ministres et de
leur demander des efforts de réduction
de leurs effectifs de leurs moyens et
qu'ils ont été dans l'ordre habituel
avançant je pense que je qualifie de
manger et élu local qui dirait que j'ai
été élu local jeu je crois connaître un
peu cette situation j'étais élue
régionale
aussi il y a trois raisons pour
lesquelles l'investissement c'est je le
conteste pas je lui dit d'ailleurs
lui-même écrit est en péril le non il
est pas en péril il a baissé alors ils
baissent systématiquement lorsqu'il ya
des renouvellements électoraux ce qui
était le cas généralement une baisse de
l'ordre de 8%
il a baissé de l'ordre de 11% c'est plus
que d'habitude c'est vrai plus que
l'habitude aussi parce que les équipes
ont quand même plus changer que
d'habitude notamment thème des ventes à
sion politique deuxième raison
l'incertitude sur un seul nombre de
textes qui sont venus à être mis en
oeuvre tardivement et nous avons au
gouvernement notre part de
responsabilité la fusion des régions a
mis du temps à se faire qu on appelle l
ou la carte des intercommunalités qui
vient d'être arrêté au 31 mars a mis du
temps à se faire
ça veut dire que des collectivités des
communes des intercommunalités qui ne
savait pas dans quelle configuration se
retrouver le lendemain avec quelles
compétences ont retardé vous le reste
aujourd'hui maintenant ça suffit vous
investissez non je le redis aujourd'hui
regardez les collectivités locales
encore un chiffre des pauses
traditionnellement trésor 30 milliards
d'euros en fin d'année l'année dernière
c'était 34 c'est à dire 4 milliards de
plus que la veille contre tous contre
tous les élus de france de droite de
gauche sont alors comment expliquer ce
phénomène inédit dont chauffer
d'abord je ne crois pas être seul
instant de deux collègues y compris au
gouvernement qui partagent cette analyse
moi c'est une analyse que je donne mais
si vous voulez baisser la dépense
publique vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que nous étions les champions d'europe
de la dépense publique mais ça pour
laquelle des études
les dépenses des collectivités
territoriales sont supérieures aux
dépenses de l'état ou faut l'avoir en
tête ou à peu près en tout cas
équivalente
donc on peut pas imaginer baisser la
dépense publique
si on ne baisse pas la dépense des
collectivités territoriales et la moins
identique d'habitude d'ailleurs c'est un
premier résultat
donc ça que je suis prêt à la
confrontation aller confrontation vous
êtes très réconfortante à sion puis
revient à ben écoute est vrai avec le
chocolat on savait les autres vous les
élus lors de je suis pas l'habitude du
thé vert
vous avez y aller au congrès des maires
non parce que je suis prêt en forme et
juliana qui va y aller cette maison de
la république te ment lorsqu'il peut
éviter la bronca du public qui sera sur
place
qu'est ce qu'il doit faire pour éviter
cette branche est généralement quand on
rend visite à quelqu'un on arrive avec
des fleurs cadeaux un livre un cadeau je
pense que l'on aura catholique fera
certain nombre de d'annonce au congrès
des maires sur la dgf la réforme de l'un
des chefs
le montant de la réduction de nos
déchets si les dotations versées par
l'état il y aura des annonces du chef de
l'état donc tu eu données de diverses
personnes de personne ne peut penser un
seul instant que le chef de l'état
n'aura pas un certain nombre de messages
apportée aux mères mais pas seulement
mer des messages des mesures oui m'enfin
vous savez les maires ne se contente pas
de paroles mais qu'est ce qui pourrait
arriver une baisse est allé dans le
temps et dans le temps sur des dotations
globales de fonctionnement ou les
territoires convié les maires il a lu le
2 juin je crois qu est-ce qu il sortira
vous pressez vous n'imaginez vous
n'imaginez pas un seul instant que
secrétaire d'état au budget d'abord
connaissent entièrement le discours du
président de la république aura lieu
dans quelques jours et quand bien même
il le connaîtrai qui vous en face paris
si des détails raviront tous les cas
vous nous apportez une information il y
aura donc des
annonce du chef de l'état devant le
congrès des maires de france ne
recevront la semaine prochaine après
l'annoncé lundi de la mfr bas quand même
elles sont attendues elles sont réjouis
beaucoup de françois baroin sera neutre
notre invité en tous les cas quand
l'information avait commencé à chuter et
vous vous aviez démenti cela à bercy
quand même un sur 20 91 geste pour les
colons mais il ya plusieurs façon d'un
nom à plusieurs choses qui peuvent être
faits en prend un peu dans des tabacs
pas trop on a bien compris le message
enfin vous ne me faites pas dire le
contraire parce que je vais dire ou de
ce que j'ai pu dire et en quelques mots
il ya il ya les dotations de l'état dont
il faut apprécier le rythme de la baisse
est aussi des mesures en faveur de
l'investissement nous avons d'ailleurs
déjà prises et qui à mon sens serait
également extrêmement utiles à la merci
pour cette précision questions sur les
collectivités toujours est-ce qui va
payer le rsa les départements où c'est
l'état qui va prendre en charge parce
que on comprend plus visiblement ces
bisbilles mon handicap vous comprenez
pas pas vous vous connaissez ce sujet le
premier ministre a clairement fait la
proposition au département de reprendre
en charge le paiement du rsa sur la base
de l'année précédente comme ça s'est
toujours fait quand il ya des transferts
de compétences ce qui représentera une
dépense supplémentaire pour l'état ou à
la verse une économie pour les
départements de l'ordre de 700 millions
d'euros et département souhaite qu'on
prenne comme référence des années
antérieures et au final c'est que le pr
mais au final la balle est dans le camp
ces jeux les départements non il y
adhérer des rencontres qui sont prévues
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochaines semaines si les départements
accepte cette proposition ils ne
payeront plus le rsa ils économiseront
700 millions d'euros si le savent mais
ils le savent où nous devons cette
information est connue et les publics
alors vous brûliez de parlé tout à
l'heure de programme de choc des
candidats à la primaire de droite pour
le budget notamment pour les
fonctionnaires écouter ce que disait il
ya quelques jours françois fillon lui il
propose une baisse importante du nombre
des fonctionnaires
bien bien supérieure aux 2% que vous
demandez aujourd'hui aux différents
ministères je propose de
passé à 39 heures le temps de travail
dans les trois fonctions publiques
je reconnais que c'est évidemment un
projet ambitieux mais il ya pour moi
absolument fondamental pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que je veux supprimer la
durée légale du travail est renvoyé à la
négociation dans les entreprises pour
que la négociation dans les entreprises
se passe correctement il faut mieux que
la référence soit 39 heures plus tôt
qu'à 35 et donc si la fonction publique
est à 39 heures la référence sera à 39
heures la deuxième raison c'est que il
faut réduire les effectifs de la
fonction publique de façon très
importante et moi je propose de les
réduire de l'ordre de 500 mille
personnes dans les trois fonctions
publiques pendant les cinq années du
quinquennat
voilà l'un des traitements de choc pour
un pays en crise est peut-être une
solution impossible que rien dans mon
point de vue c'est un possible suicide
monsieur fillon peut dire ce qu'il veut
il a été promise de ce pays je crois
pendant cinq ans dire des choses
pareilles c'est se faire plaisir c'est
peut-être faire plaisir à certains mais
c'est complètement impossible aux
cheveux jeudi deuxièmement monsieur
fillon d'y faire travailler 39 heures
mais il dit pas s'il paye 39 ou 35
heures moi qui le disent
lui dit aux gens tuent aujourd'hui outre
les 35 heures zone est très 39 heures
mais si c'est pour le même salaire et le
dit pas je sais pas comment il va faire
autre élément sais pas monsieur fillon
sarkozy je crois qu'ils pourront parler
de la baisse de l'impôt
enfin il propose aussi d'imposer aux
collectivités territoriales de ne pas de
ne plus embaucher au moment du départ en
retraite
comment ils peuvent être sûrs d'eux et
comment il peut le faire la constitution
dans notre pays donne la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales dans le cadre des lois du
pays
je te vois que vous êtes toujours
aujourd'hui tout le monde est vent
debout contre une baisse des dotations
kinky kylie ce qui mettrait le pays est
encore augmenter les recettes de des
collectivités locales vous allez à
redire que qu'il ne remplace pas leurs
fonctionnaires de façon autoritaire
ceci c'est une politique de gribouille
et cent mille fonctionnaires à bercy
nous sommes allés ministère qui supprime
le plus emploi du moindre là par exemple
dans la direction générale des finances
publiques deux mille 2000 et c'est
difficile je voulais vous montre les
lettres des maires des sénateurs des
députés
les républicains qui m'écrivent il ne
faut pas à tarbes ferme et à lagence
telle trésorerie ne faut pas à agen il
ne faut pas à bordeaux regroupe en effet
quand elle va promettre la rupture alors
ils vous promettent alors que nous
faisons 2000 suppressions d'emplois à
bercy il vous en promettent cent mille
par an mais souci était impossible bien
entendu le fmi est encore aujourd'hui
parce qu'on en a parlé déjà tout à
l'heure qui veut dire que la situation
des forêts s'est améliorée bien entendu
mais qu'il fallait rationaliser sur les
fonctionnaires là aussi c'est ce que
propose françois fillon ce que propose
alain juppé mais nous faisons nous le
faisons nous avons décidé d'embaucher 10
mille enseignants supplémentaires tous
les ans nous l'avons fait nous avons
voudra encore plus nous avons demandé
maintenant organiser l'embauchent que
plus de policiers de plusieurs gendarmes
et nous y avons été je vais dire en plus
encourager même contre un contenu de la
situation relativement au terrorisme
nous avions prévu de baisser les
effectifs dans l'armée nous y avons
renoncé contenu la fac nécessaire mais
vous dites aux effets mais ça y est dans
les autres ministères
je voulais dit dg fipd ministère de
l'environnement d'autres organismes y
compris dans des organismes
d'enseignement nous
nous avons des des réductions de
personnels qui sont extrêmement
importantes que tout le monde trouve
assuré questions d'actualité encore oui
est-ce qu'il faut une loi sur la
rémunération des patrons
oui et ça veut dire que c'est presque
une réponse réflexe que vous nous faites
non c'est ce que c'est ce que dit
emmanuel marc aujourd'hui dans les et
qu'une loi fut noah c'est de réponse
réflexe c'est à dire un problème une loi
mais moi je veux vous croyez qu avant de
répondre à votre question je n'ai pas
réfléchi premièrement on a vu au travers
d'exemples récents que l'assemblée
générale des actionnaires n'est pas
entendue lorsqu'elle refuse une
augmentation scandaleuse excessive dix
ans deux d'un dirigeant d'entreprise
deuxièmement michel sapin premier
ministre ont clairement indiqué dans les
travaux actuellement en cours au moment
où on se parle à l'assemblée nationale
sur la loi 50 2 il y aurait un certain
nombre d'amendements qui donnerait plus
de pouvoir aux actionnaires pour éviter
un noir ne soit pas entendu une loi un
mois complètement tout cas la gr il y
aura des passages dans la loi sapin qui
vont concerner cette question qu'à sion
et 4 2017 s'approche à grand pas que
vous avez vu les sondages même mais ils
mettront tout en haut
françois hollande tout en bas ça vous
inquiète non pas du tout pas du tout bon
je je je je n'ai pas l'oeil rivé au
sondage se voulait dit tout à l'heure
avec moi je suis secrétaire d'état
depuis un peu plus de deux ans c'est une
responsabilité
je pars donner un ton un peu plus grave
à notre entretien mai
pensez pas que les femmes les hommes qui
qui qui à qui on délègue le pouvoir au
nom du peuple français
ne croyez pas qu'ils ont parfois se pose
des questions sur la pertinence de
l'indécision
pour nous c'est extrêmement important
mais on ne le fait pas à l'aune de ce
qui va se passer au moment des élections
suivantes face à la crise ont messi
c'est quelque part votre question parce
que vous ne dites pas alors macro et la
hollande est là je pense que françois le
président a fait a pris à son nombre de
responsabilités qui nécessairement tenu
à des équilibres parfois des déceptions
non mais souvent des des deux côtés
responsabilité du ministre de l'économie
n'est pas la même très bien en tous les
cas on a bien compris ce que vous venez
de nous dire quand vous devrez jauger de
la possibilité d'une baisse d'impôts en
2010 est à bercy vous ne le ferez pas en
pensant à la présidentielle c'est ce que
vous avez dit merci merci cristie kerr
la semaine prochaine la semaine
prochaine c'est françois baroin le
président de l'association des maires de
france justement l'équipe
vous avez beaucoup de sujets sur la
table on l'a vue qui sera notre invité
bon soir ou pas qu'il oublie qu'il a été
aussi secrétaires d'état ou ministres
des finances il est moins excessif que
certains bradent vous avez vu sur la
belle derrière pau 1